Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Jetzt ist es passiert. Neymar wechselt für 222 Millionen von Barca zu PSG. Was bedeutet das eigentlich und was wird jetzt passieren? Auch sportlich gesehen. Darüber spreche ich mit Ben Barthmann von SPOX. Ben, ich grüße dich. Sehr schön, dass das mal mit deiner Rasenfunk-Premiere hier klappt. Zeit wird's, mehr Leute von SPOX hier mit dabei zu haben. Ben, du bist Experte für La Liga. Das muss man sogar so sagen, wenn ich deinem Chef unter anderem glauben darf, der mich an dich vermittelt hat. Neymar Wechsel zu PSG, der Blockbuster-Trade, oder wie auch immer man das jetzt eigentlich nennen mag. Wenn ich dir das gesagt hätte, zum Ende der letzten Saison hättest du das für möglich gehalten?
Das ist eine gute Frage zum Start gleich, denn ich würde durchaus sagen ja, weil man dann immer das Gefühl hatte, wenn in der nächsten Zeit einer der großen Spieler Barcelona verlässt, dann ist es Neymar. Das hat sich immer so ein bisschen angedeutet, vielleicht wenn man gerade seinen Vater und den Rest außen herum kennt. Und auch wenn man ihn selbst kennt, denke ich, wenn, dann Neymar.
Und warum?
Gerade weil man immer das Gefühl hatte, was jetzt das Umfeld von Neymar angeht, dass er in Barcelona ist, weil da gutes Geld verdient werden kann, weil er auch was Marketing angeht, in der Weltspitze sich bewegt. Und was ihn angeht, weil er schon Ambitionen hat, sowohl sportlich als auch neben dem Platz. Auch wenn man es nicht in seinen Kopf hinein sehen kann, aber ich denke, man kann es dann doch ein bisschen ansehen. Und gerade die Weltfußballer-Sache oder der Ballon d'Or scheint ihm da enorm wichtig zu sein. Und das ist halt dann doch relativ schwierig, wenn man neben Lionel Messi spielt.
Das heißt, das ist wahrscheinlich der sportlich wichtigste Grund, dass er gerne diese Einzelauszeichnung gewinnen würde. Und das klappt im Team mit Messi schwieriger, als wenn er quasi seine eigenen Leistungen nur beschreibt.
Das ist ja so die allgemeine Wahrnehmung. Jetzt ist natürlich dann die Frage, wie das per PSG funktionieren soll, aber das muss man wahrscheinlich einfach abwarten.
Ja, das fragt er sich wahrscheinlich auch. An diesem Wechsel hängt ja ganz viel dran, aber bevor wir da so ein bisschen ins Detail gehen möchten, habe ich noch eine andere Frage bezogen auf die Primärer Division. Was ist denn eigentlich mit Cristiano Ronaldo? Denn da hatten wir ganz ähnliche, wenn auch irgendwie anders gelagerte Gerüchte Anfang des Sommers. Hat sich das eigentlich alles wieder erledigt? Ich finde da drüber nicht mehr so viel.
Das scheint sich erledigt zu haben, ja. Ich denke der große Sprung in diesen Gerüchten wurde ja gemacht, als er gerade mit der Steueraffäre in Verbindung gebracht wurde. Es gab auch davor schon immer mal wieder so vereinzelte Gerüchte, aber diese große Wolke kam dann eigentlich nur durch diese Steuersache, und die scheint man ja zuversichtlich zu sein, die irgendwie lösen zu können. Dementsprechend hat sich das anscheinend erledigt. Das hat so ein bisschen damit begonnen, dass Pérez, der Realpräsident, sich öffentlich geäußert hat und eben auch ganz klar gesagt hat, dass er Ronaldo nicht ziehen lässt.
Okay, naja gut, das Zuversichtliche bei Gerichtsprozessen, Uli Hoeneß war auch immer sehr zuversichtlich, dass das alles klappt. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Erklär mir doch mal bitte kurz und den Hörern und Hörern damit auch, wie hat denn jetzt dieser Neymar-Wechsel funktioniert? Er hatte eine festgeschriebene Ausstiegsklausel von 222 Millionen Euro. Wer hat die gezahlt?
Das ist ja die große Frage, die auch die Liga aus Spanien bewegt hat. Grundsätzlich bezahlt ja der aufnehmende Verein, in den meisten Fällen zumindest, in den normalen Fällen. In diesem Fall gab es jetzt Berichte, ob die richtig sind oder nicht. Das wird sich dann wahrscheinlich erst durch eine Untersuchung der UEFA zeigen, dass der Sportfor aus Katar da nachgeholfen hat, der ja gleichzeitig auch bei PSG involviert ist. Und wahrscheinlich Neymar dieses Geld zur Verfügung gestellt hat, was dann wieder relativ normal ist. Das wurde auch bei Javi Martinez zum Beispiel so gelöst, als er von Atletik Bilbao nach München kam.
Da hat ihm dann Bayern das Geld zur Verfügung gestellt, oder?
Genau, der Spieler muss seine Vertragsklausel selbst ziehen und ist dann praktisch frei für die Verhandlungen mit dem aufnehmenden Club. Die große Diskussionssache ist jetzt eben die Frage, kam das Geld von PSG und wie ist das mit dem Financial Fair Play der UEFA zu vereinigen? Oder kam das Geld eben aus Katar und wurde dann da bewusst diese Regelungen umgangen?
Also es gibt ja zumindest Gerüchte darüber, bestätigt war es man da nichts, dass er WM-Botschafter der WM in Katar werden soll und dafür einen Ex-Orbitantonen-Betrag bekommt, zumindest meiner Wahrnehmung nach. Und dass eben genau dieses Geld sein könnte. Das ist ja die Konstellation, über die wir sprechen.
Genau, aber wie du sagst, das ist eben ein Gerücht und bis jetzt weiß man auch von offizieller Seite noch überhaupt nichts. Nur, dass diese Klausel eben gestern gezogen wurde und bezahlt wurde. Nachdem die spanische Liga sich weigerte, das Geld anzunehmen, dann eben direkt an den Verein.
Warum hat sich die Liga geweigert? Auf welche Rechtsgrundlage eigentlich? Das habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz verstanden.
Die Liga hat tatsächlich keine Rechtsgrundlage.
Ah, okay, Sie haben einfach gesagt, danke, wir brauchen keine 222 Millionen.
Ja, normalerweise wird bei solchen Transfers das Geld dann bei der Liga hinterlegt und wird dann weitergeleitet. Aber eine rechtliche Grundlage für die Ablehnung dessen gibt es nicht, da ja die Ausstiegsklausel, wie es in Spanien verpflichtend ist, festgeschrieben wurde. Und ganz normal gezogen wurde der Javier Tevas, der Präsident der Liga. Das ist aber wieder eine Verbotung, meinerseits nur versucht, auf den Transfer aufmerksam zu machen und besonders zu zeigen, dass die Liga hier ein Marketing-Zugpferd verliert. Und da ist noch mal irgendwie der UEFA auf jeden Fall zeigen wollte, dass da Widerstand da war oder da ist.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Glaubst du, dass Ausstiegsklauseln in Zukunft jetzt noch viel häufiger in so utropischen Höhlen liegen werden? Man spricht davon, dass Cristiano Ronaldo eine festgeschriebene Ablösesumme von einer Milliarde Euro hat. Jetzt sind die 222 Millionen anscheinend noch für gewisse Personen auf diesem Erdkreis finanzierbar. Könnte das sein, dass wir in Zukunft Ausstiegsklauseln noch mehr in so Fantastiliardensummen haben, damit man so ein Szenario wie das jetzt abfängt?
Also gerade wenn wir über den Fonds aus Katar reden, dann sprechen wir ja über eine dreistellige Milliardensumme anscheinend. Die da bereit steht, dass sie natürlich nicht für Transfers verwendet wird, dass dann wieder eine andere Sache ausschließlich für Transfers verwendet wird. Aber grundsätzlich hat man jetzt gesehen, dass die Bereitschaft auf jeden Fall da ist, auch derartige Höhen zu gehen. Und ich denke, dass gerade in Spanien und Portugal beispielsweise, wo Ausstiegsklauseln verpflichtend sind in den Spielerverträgen, kann man schon damit rechnen, dass die Klauseln jetzt sehr hoch angesetzt werden. Die waren ja auch bislang eigentlich immer nicht ziehbar, wenn man das so sieht. Ich habe vorhin mal was gelesen. Ich glaube, Dani Cavajal von Real Madrid kostet 350 Millionen Euro. Aber ich denke gerade im Fall Neymar ist da vielleicht auch einfach die Klausel dann so angesetzt gewesen, dass man gesagt hat, da passiert eh nichts und jetzt ist eben doch was passiert. Also ja, gerade in den Fällen von Spielern auf diesem Niveau, denke ich, kann man durchaus erwarten, dass die Vereine versuchen werden, es noch höher anzusetzen.
Ich meine, es liegt natürlich auch im Interesse der Spieler, dass man nicht auf eine Milliarde taxiert wird, damit man eben diese Möglichkeit hat. Also Neymar hatte jetzt diese Möglichkeit zu wechseln, auch nur weil eben diese 222 Millionen noch finanzierbar waren und das ist natürlich ein Interesse, was er auch bei Abschluss des Vertrages hatte. Aber es zeigt schon, in welchen Dimensionen man sich da bewegt. Was wird denn so berichtet, wie teuer kommt PSG bzw. allen beteiligt, muss man ja glaube ich eher sagen. Dieser Deal jetzt insgesamt, ich habe da mal was gelesen von 600 Millionen Euro, habe auch mal was gelesen von 800 Millionen Euro, ganz genau weiß man es nicht, aber kannst du uns so ein Gefühl für die Größenordnung geben, inklusive Gehalt, Handgelder und so weiter?
Da muss man ja klar unterscheiden, einmal zwischen Ablöse und einmal zwischen Handgeldern oder Gehältern, das hat mir schon beim Transfer von Neymar von Santos zu Barcelona nicht ganz gefallen, weil da ja auch von Summen gesprochen wird, im Bereich von 80 Millionen oder höher. Die tatsächliche Ablöse, glaube ich, hat sich im Bereich von 40 bis 50 Millionen bewegt, es kommt immer darauf an, wie man sämtliche Nebenzahlungen rechnet und der Rest waren ja tatsächlich Handgelder, die auch in anderen Transfers fließen, aber da nicht mit in die Ablösesumme hinein berechnet werden. Dementsprechend ist es schwer, eine genaue Summe zu nennen. Ich habe auch die 60 Millionen gelesen, von denen du sprichst. Das wären dann aber tatsächlich Ablöse, Handgelder und Gehälter über die gesamte Vertragslaufzeit hinweg. Und dann muss eben auch noch steuerrechtlich müsste dann noch gesehen werden, wie denn diese Zahlung an Neymar, damit er seine Vertragsklausel lösen kann, dann betrachtet wird, da die je nach dem, wie der Staat das einordnet als Gehaltszahlung oder als Auslage, wie auch immer man das dann betitelt, unterschiedlich besteuert werden würde. Und so wie die Medien natürlich berichten, nehmen sie da die höchste Steuersumme, damit sich das Ganze dann noch möglichst hoch anhört, denke ich.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich so was vermutet, deswegen bin ich froh, dass du das mal aufgedröset hast. Also genau werden wir es ja sowieso nie erfahren. Siehst du denn eine Möglichkeit, in der das im Rahmen des Financial Fair Play noch stattgefunden haben kann, dieser Wechsel, ohne dass da irgendwelche Tricksereien in dem Sinne gemacht wurden, dass PSG nur einen Teil des Aufwands tragen muss und der andere Teil des Aufwands über eben unter anderem diesen Fonds aus Qatar abgefangen wird. Denn das Financial Fair Play sagt ja sehr verkürzt, du darfst nicht mehr ausgeben, als du einnimmst.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr verkürzt. Es gibt natürlich seine Schlupflöcher und seine Möglichkeiten, aber dennoch denke ich, dass 222 Millionen natürlich schon eine enorme Verlusssumme erstmal sind, die man da stehen hat. Und ich glaube, das Financial Fair Play setzt sich dann aus drei Jahren zusammen, denen man nicht mehr ausgeben darf, als man eingenommen hat. Und auch über diese drei Jahre wäre es dann eben schon ein enormer Aufwand, das auszugleichen, was dann wiederum nicht damit vereinbar wäre, was Pejea sagt, sie wollen mit Neymar in die absolute europäische Spitze vorstoßen. Und ob das dann eben vereinbar ist mit dementsprechenden Einnahmen durch Spielertransfers, halte ich für fraglich. Das müsste dann anderswoher kommen. Und da hat die UEFA ja dann eben doch sehr klare Regeln, die aber auch wieder sicherlich irgendwie Umgang werden können. Also man merkt vielleicht auch, dass es einfach eine neue Regelung noch ist, die ihre Schlupflöcher hat und die hoffentlich dann auch in der Zukunft gestopft werden können. Aber dafür braucht es eben vielleicht solche Präzedenzfalle.
Ja, da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher. Ich meine, allein wenn man sich die Konstellationen aller Beteiligten anguckt, dann sieht man auch den Sponsor Nike, der sowohl Neymar als Einzelpersonen-Sponsor hat, als auch den Club-PSG. Du hast die Kataris, die eben auch hinter dem Verein PSG stehen und eben noch ihren eigenen Fonds haben, der sich fern von jeder normalen Vorstellungskraft in finanziellen Höhen bewegt. Irgendwie wird man da doch immer ein Set-up finden können, wo man sagen kann, ja gut, dann zahlt halt Nike jetzt. Ich mach jetzt mal ein Szenario auf. Nike sagt einfach, ach komm, wir zahlen pro Saison einfach 200 Millionen für das Sponsoring bei PSG und damit wird dann indirekter Transfer finanziert und dann ist es irgendwie auch irgendwie auch geregelt.
Ja, ich denke solche Regelungen werden sie sicher suchen. Und gerade wenn du Nike ansprichst, muss man auch über den wirtschaftlichen Wert von Neymar eben sprechen, der das absolute Nike, das Nike-Aushängeschild eigentlich ist. Ähnlich wie Pogba bei Adidas. Das heißt, eine Beteiligung kann ich mir da durchaus vorstellen.
So, und jetzt haben wir schon eine ganze Weile über diesen Transfer gesprochen, aber noch nicht über das Sportliche. Darum soll es ja eigentlich ums Sportliche gehen. Was bedeutet das denn für Barcelona? Also Neymar, vier Jahre war er da, hat in 163 Spielen war er an 161 Toren beteiligt. Eine unfassbare Quote, aber halt auch in einem Team der unfassbaren Quoten. Also die haben ja alle herausragende Quoten da vorne drin. Was bedeutet das sportlich?
Das ist für Barcelona auf jeden Fall ein harter Schlag. Man muss natürlich immer noch mit Lionel Messi als zentrale Figur der Mannschaft rechnen, aber ich denke gerade in den nächsten Jahren hätte Neymar sicherlich auch mehr Verantwortung tragen sollen. Frage ist immer, ob er das im Stil eines Messi kann. Das würde ich ein bisschen bezweifeln, weil er am Ende ein anderer Spielertyp ist. Er ist keiner dieser Spielmacher, wie Messi sich entwickelt hat. Er ist mehr ein Läufer und Tore-Schließer. Er ist deutlich zu niedrig angesetzt, aber er hat seine Stärken eben im 1 gegen 1 außen. Sicher auch im 2 gegen 1 mit zwei Gegenspielern kann er auch noch lösen. Er hat einen präzisen Abschluss. Er weiß, welche Wege er für Messi auch machen muss. Man hat dementsprechend auch jetzt unter Wahlwerte in den ersten Vorbereitungspartien sehr viele Tore erzielt. Das heißt, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, die Tore hätte auch jeder andere Blinde auf der Position geschossen. Das würde ich auf gar keinen Fall sagen. Ich würde aber gleichzeitig auch bezweifeln, dass er tatsächlich irgendwann für Messi übernehmen könnte. Das wäre nicht ohne eine entsprechende Teamanpassung möglich gewesen.
Also Messi jetzt 30 Jahre alt, Neymar 25 Jahre. Das sind die Altersdimensionen, in denen wir uns bewegen. Jetzt ist ja bei Barcelona sowieso gerade nicht alles Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen. Wir erinnern uns an das Ausscheiden in der Champions League letzte Saison. Wir wissen, wie lange die letzten Titel schon wieder zurücklagen in Barca Dimensionen. Liebe Schalke-Fans, bitte jetzt nicht weinen bei diesem Part. Wie ist denn so die Gemengelage bei Barca?
Das ist speziell in dieser Saison oder in der kommenden Saison jetzt zu beobachten. Das wird ein sehr spannendes Jahr. Einerseits eben, weil man Neymar verloren hat, auf der anderen Seite auch, weil ein neuer Trainer da ist und weil zentrale Bauteile der Mannschaft dann langsam Schritt für Schritt auch neuen Rollen entgegengehen müssen. Man hat das letztes Jahr gesehen, dass es nicht geschafft wurde, Dani Alves in irgendeiner Form wirklich zu ersetzen. Das konnten sämtliche Kandidaten, die dort ausprobiert wurden, nicht. Ähnlich wird es mit Andrés Iniesta passieren oder mit Lionel Messi. Aber der Grundbaustein dafür muss jetzt oder wurde zum Teil auch schon in der vergangenen Saison gelegt. Und wie es dann immer ist, bei solchen Zukunftsplanungen muss eben abgewartet werden, wie sich das Ganze entwickelt. Das kann niemand prognostizieren, aber man kann gute Vorbereitungen treffen und die sind nur zum Teil getroffen worden, meine ich.
Da gehört er als erstes schon mal der Trainer mit rein. Was kannst du denn über Walwerde sagen? Was für ein Typ ist er und wie hat er sich jetzt bei Barca bisher eingefügt, auch wenn wir jetzt nur die Eindrücke aus der Vorbereitung haben?
Walwerde hat sich tatsächlich sehr gut eingefügt. Man muss aber dazu sagen, dass er von Anfang an nicht der Wunschkandidat war. Er war auch nicht sonderlich beliebt direkt von Anfang an. Viele hatten sich Sampa Oli als Trainer gewünscht, der mit Sevilla eine sehr, sehr gute Hinrunde und Teil der Rückrunde gespielt hat und dann ein bisschen eingestürzt ist. Und der letztlich auch zu haben gewesen wäre, er hat sich zum argentinischen Nationalteam gewechselt. Das war der große Wunschkandidat vieler in Barcelona. Mit Walwerde hat man jetzt einen profillos, ist zu viel gesagt, aber einen relativ normalen Trainer, würde ich behaupten, von der Außendarstellung her bekommen, der keine großen Reden hält, der seine Arbeit macht und der auf seinen letzten Stationen eigentlich immer gute Mannschaften trainiert hat, aber selten Erfolge gefeiert hat, was sicherlich auch an der Qualität lag, die ihm zur Verfügung stand.
Also war er jetzt zuletzt bei Valencia und Bilbao, waren die letzten beiden Stationen.
Und gerade dort hat er, denke ich, sehr gut gezeigt, dass er mit dem Material arbeiten kann, dass er gestellt bekommt. Das hat man bei Enrique immer ein bisschen kritisiert, der sehr stark die Mannschaft auf dieses MSN vorne mit Neymar, Luis Suárez und Lionel Messi ausgerichtet hat und dahinter die Struktur ein bisschen verloren hat. Gerade was das Mittelfeld an ging – Barcelona war ja immer eine Mannschaft, die sich über das zentrale Mittelfeld definiert hat unter Pep Guardiola und auch Tito Villanova oder Jauri Roura. Der Fokus hat sich eben ein bisschen verschoben unter Luis Enrique in die vorderste Reihe, in die Stürmerreihe. Gerade mit Valverde, der angekündigt hat, wieder aufs Mittelfeld setzen zu wollen. Ist dann aber die Frage, was kann er eben aus dieser Qualität machen, die im Mittelfeld vorhanden ist? Ist das überhaupt noch gut genug, um wirklich den Fokus auf das Mittelfeld zu legen? Und gerade da ist dann eben auch die Frage nach den Spielern, die es zur Verfügung hat. Und momentan fehlt da auf jeden Fall noch ein sehr guter, bis herausragender Mittelfeldspieler. Weshalb dann eben auch über Marco Verratti so viel gesprochen wurde, den man jetzt wohl definitiv nicht bekommen wird.
Was glaubst du, wird da noch passieren? Also sowohl jetzt im Mittelfeld – du hast es schon angesprochen – da hat man bisher noch gar niemanden geholt, außer jetzt im defensiven Mittelfeld, Sergi Samper. Aber da bin ich jetzt nicht sicher, ob das jetzt schon die Lösung ist. Sowohl im Mittelfeld als auch als Nachfolge für Neymar. Glaubst du, dass Barca da jetzt überhaupt darauf vorbereitet war? Denn wenn du es hast kommen sehen, dann werden es ja wohl die Verantwortlichen, zumindest auch irgendwie in der Schublade gehabt haben, diese Möglichkeit, dass Neymar wechselt.
Joseph-Maria Bartomeu hat da vor ein paar Tagen, könnten inzwischen auch schon zwei Wochen sein, mal allgemein auf einen Transfer von Neymar angesprochen, gesagt, sollte er gehen, als es diese ersten Gerüchte gab, würde auf jeden Fall ein Nachfolger kommen und die entsprechende Ablöse, also er hat auch damals schon gesagt, wer den haben will, muss diese festgeschriebene Klausel bezahlen, würde auch in weitere Verstärkungen investiert werden, das heißt, den Verantwortlichen ist durchaus bewusst, dass sie da was machen müssen. Dass man Neymar-Abgang nicht vorhersehen kann, denke ich, ist klar und man kann auch schlecht vorsorgen, dass sich kein Spieler auf die Bank setzen will, das hat man auf den Transfermarkt jetzt mehrfach gesehen, denke ich, und darauf warten will, dass Neymar, Messi oder Suárez einer von den drei irgendwann mal verletzt ist. Man hat damit Paco Alcácer letzte Saison sehr, sehr viel Geld ausgegeben für einen Spieler, der im oberen Durchschnitt der Spanischen Liga sich bewegt, der aber anscheinend bereit dazu war, diese Rolle zu übernehmen, das war dann dementsprechend viel Geld wert. Er konnte die Rolle aber nicht wirklich ausfüllen, also er hat eine relativ schlechte erste Saison gespielt, die Ansätze sind aber sicher da, er ist noch jung und er wird da auch nicht vorzeitig abgeschossen, damit rechne ich nicht, aber es muss für Neymar ein Nachfeuer kommen, für die erste Elf auch. Das Problem ist, es ist Anfang August, das heißt es ist nur noch weniger als einen Monat Zeit, die meisten Vereine werden ihre Planung größtenteils abgeschlossen haben, gerade die großen Vereine. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt über Namen reden wie Antoine Griezmann oder Kylian Mbappé, dann redet man wahrscheinlich über Transfers, die nicht möglich sind. Auf der anderen Seite hat man jetzt den Vorteil, man sucht nicht mehr eine Nummer 4 für den Sturm, sondern man sucht einen Stammspieler. Das könnte natürlich gerade im Fall Mbappé oder im Fall Usman Dembele von Borussia Dortmund vielleicht auch nochmal was auslösen, dass diese Spieler sagen, diese Chance ist jetzt da und nicht in den nächsten vier oder fünf Jahren, sondern jetzt. Und dann kann ich vielleicht auf meinen Club auch Druck ausüben und meine Freigabe bitten. Und dann könnte sich vielleicht noch ein Transfer geben. Daran wird sich Barcelona auf jeden Fall versuchen müssen. Und wenn wir dann ins Mittelfeld schauen, muss man sagen, wie gesagt, der sehr gute bis herrausragende Mittelfeldspiel fehlt auf jeden Fall noch. Ansonsten ist der Kader aber, denke ich, relativ gut aufgestellt. Gerade weil man eben einen Trainer hat mit, weil Werder, der auch darauf setzt, was er hat. Du hast vorhin Sampa angesprochen, der ja von seiner Laie zurückgekehrt ist. Der hat in den Vorbereitungsspielen einige Zeit bekommen. Der hat auch gut ausgesehen. Ist gerade ein Spieler, der sehr gut in das System von Barcelona passt und der jetzt im spanischen Abstiegskampf sich auch noch mal ein paar Erfahrungen gemacht hat mit Gennara. Das wäre schön, wenn man den einbauen kann, weil er wirklich ein Lamassier-Spieler ist und das vielleicht auch mal manchen kritischen Stimmen über die Jugendarbeit wieder ein bisschen Feuer nehmen würde.
Jetzt hast du schon ein paar Spieler genannt. Dembele, Bape, Griezmann. Fürs Mittelfeld wird auch über Coutinho viel gesprochen. Wenn wir jetzt aber erstmal auf den Neymar-Nachfolger gucken, wir werden, wir beide haben keine Glaskugel hier und wissen nicht, was passiert. Und es könnte sein, dass da jetzt einiges noch mal ins Rollen kommt auf dem europäischen Transfermarkt, vielleicht aber auch nicht. Wenn wir jetzt aber mal nur auf die Fähigkeiten gucken, die man haben muss auf der Position, wenn man bei Barca spielt, wer würde denn deiner Einschätzung nach am besten passen?
Ich selber würde mich für Dembele aussprechen, denke ich. Einerseits, weil ich glaube, dass man ihn bekommen würde, auch jetzt noch, solange man den Spieler davon überzeugen kann für einen Wechsel. Und der dann dementsprechend auch um die Freigabe eben bittet, denke ich, dass da was möglich ist. Auf jeden Fall mehr als bei Griezmann oder Eden Hazard, wenn man so was liest. Gleichzeitig hat er diese Fähigkeiten, die ich sage, die er im Spiel von Barcelona braucht. Das heißt, er findet in engen Räumen konstant gute Lösungen eigentlich. Oder immer konstanter. Das hat sich in dieser Saison auch entwickelt. Ich habe mal bei Twitter von Martin Raffelt gelesen, er hat das Gefühl, dass Dembele so wie ein Koli-Bri funktioniert, der die Welt langsamer sieht. Ich denke, das beschreibt sein Spiel sehr, sehr gut. Weil er tatsächlich auch wirklich in allerengsten Situationen, die er in diesem Ballbesitzspiel mit tiefstehenden Gegnern immer wieder auftreten, eine Lösung findet, weil er kreativ ist, weil er stark im 1 gegen 1 ist, weil er sich was traut und weil er dementsprechend eigentlich sehr nah an Neymar dran sein könnte. Gerade im Bezug auf Torgefährlichkeit kann man vielleicht noch arbeiten, aber das kommt dann auch immer ein bisschen auf die Ausrichtung der Mannschaft darauf an und welche Rolle er genau übernehmen soll. Da ja am Ende Messi eigentlich immer der Spieler ist, der auf alle anderen Spieler ausstrahlt, also so wie er eingebaut wird, so wie er funktioniert. Muss man dann eben sehen, was die anderen Spieler machen müssen, weil ich denke, dass ein Duo aus Messi, Dembélé, mit Suárez, mit Iniesta sehr gut funktionieren könnte. Gerade bei Mbappé bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Der hat zum Teil auch sehr viel in der zentralen Spitze gespielt. Der bringt ein bisschen anderes Paket mit an Fähigkeiten. Da weiß ich nicht, inwiefern das vereinbar wäre. Das heißt, Dembélé halte ich für die wahrscheinlichste und auch für die beste Option.
Und wenn wir aufs Mittelfeld gucken, da ragt natürlich Iniesta immer noch heraus. Xavi hat ihn jetzt schon vor einiger Zeit verloren. Das ist ja noch so die Generation, mit der wir beide wahrscheinlich noch so sozialisiert wurden. Ist Iniesta immer noch auf dem Höhepunkt seines Schaffens oder muss man sich da nicht vielleicht auch langsam schon mal bereit dafür machen, einen Nachfolger zu suchen?
Da muss man sich auf jeden Fall dazu bereit machen. Man hat es auch zum Teil schon versucht, denke ich. Mit Dennis Suárez hat man sich beispielsweise ein bisschen mit Jugend verstärkt, der auch eine ähnliche Rolle spielen könnte. Wenn man jetzt die Gerüchte um Coutinho hört, geht es vielleicht auch ein bisschen in die Richtung. Aber es ist nicht so, dass Iniesta in der nächsten Saison beispielsweise schon ins zweite Glied rutschen soll. Er ist auf jeden Fall noch ein wichtiger Teil des Teams. Man muss sich nur vielleicht langsam in eine andere Rolle einfügen, so wie es mit Xavi auch gemacht wurde, der immer noch eine Rolle einnimmt, aber nicht mehr die alles entscheidende Rolle in seinem Mannschaftsteil, sondern er muss sich halt ein bisschen anpassen. Er muss wissen, welche Spiele er pausieren muss, wann er vielleicht auch mal nicht gebraucht wird. Vor allem, weil er auch in den letzten Jahren immer mehr Taktgeber war, was vorher Xavi übernommen hat. Diese Rolle musste er jetzt ausfüllen und ich denke, diese Entwicklung wird sich auch noch weiterziehen, bis man dann eben irgendwann so weit ist wie bei Xavi vor ein paar Jahren und sagt, er kommt jetzt, um das Spiel nochmal zu beruhigen, um die letzten Minuten, die letzte halbe Stunde vielleicht nochmal den Ball sicher laufen zu lassen.
Der edelste aller edel Joker.
Genau. Also nicht unbedingt nur ein Joker, aber sicher einer, der seine Rolle in der Mannschaft mit der Zeit verändern muss. Ob das in dieser Saison passiert oder in der übernächsten Saison, aber ich denke, es ist erforderlich, um auch eine gute Perspektive zu zeigen und seine Fähigkeiten, die er unbestritten natürlich immer noch hat und auch haben wird, bestmöglich einzusetzen.
Wenn wir uns jetzt generell die Situation in La Liga anschauen, dann sehen wir bei Real Madrid, also Cristiano Ronaldo bleibt wohl doch trotz aller Gerüchte, dann hat man sich fürs zentrale Mittelfeld einen Dani Ceballos geholt, der auch Barca sehr gut zu Gesicht gestanden hätte. Letzte Saison ist Real mit drei Punkten Vorsprung vor Barca meister geworden, Atletico schon deutlich dahinter mit 15 Punkten Rückstand. Was erwartest du jetzt für die aktuelle Saison in der Spanischen Liga? Wird es wieder ein Dreikampf? Ist es vielleicht jetzt noch deutlicher in Richtung Real Madrid das Pendel ausgeschlagen mit diesem Wechsel?
Das kommt halt zu einem sehr, sehr großen Teil auf den direkten Vergleich darauf an. Und ich denke, dass Barcelona auch ohne Neymar absolut in der Lage ist, Real Madrid zu schlagen. Darüber müssen wir gar nicht diskutieren, denke ich. Es kommt halt sehr viel auf die Konstanz darauf an. Das bedeutet Kaderdichte. Wie kann ich meine Leistungen trotz Champions League, trotz Pokal und Co. über die Saison ziehen? Und da sehe ich jetzt auch bei Barcelona keine großen Probleme kommen oder so was. Also es wird mindestens ein Zweikampf, wenn der DT Co. wieder eine gute bis sehr gute Saison eigentlich spielt. Also sie brauchen wirklich eine sehr gute Saison mitzuspielen ganz oben. Sind die auch dabei. Aber letztlich, was man vielleicht momentan tatsächlich sagen muss, ist, dass Real Madrid einen sehr guten bis herausragenden Kader einfach hat von der Zusammenstellung her. Das heißt, Barcelona muss vielleicht ein bisschen kreativer sein in der in der Lösungsfindung jetzt gerade nach dem Neymar-Abgang. Aber wir werden auf jeden Fall bis zum Ende einen Zweikampf sehen, denke ich.
Und wenn du jetzt mal noch so ein bisschen ein Fazit unter diesen ganzen Wechsel machen müsstest, die Katalanen gelten als ein sehr stolzer Volksschlag. Das merkt man auch, wenn man in Barcelona ist. Also das ist jetzt auch, glaube ich, nicht nur daher gesagt. Und es steht ja auch quasi stellvertretend für die ganze Region. Ist das jetzt ein Rückschlag für Barca, dem man mit umso größerem Trotz begegnen wird? Oder was macht das mit dem ganzen Fall? Oder ist es vielleicht so einer der Einschnitte, wo wir sagen, da konnte man sehen, bei Barca zerfaserte es langsam so und diese Zeit des Zweikampfes mit Real Madrid, die uns ja jetzt wirklich so durch die 2000er Jahre begleitet hat, ist vielleicht mal zumindest kurz unterbrochen?
Nein, das würde ich so nicht sagen. Also Barcelona hat einen Spieler verloren, sie haben einen sehr guten Spieler verloren, aber es ist am Ende immer noch Barcelona. Sie werden ihre Lösung finden und sie werden halt einfach einen neuen Weg gehen müssen. Natürlich hat man Neymar verloren, das steckt niemand einfach so weg und spielt dann genauso wie zuvor, sondern man wird sich eben anpassen müssen. Es ist einfach, ich würde es positiv sehen, einfach mal und sagen, man hat jetzt die Möglichkeit, einen neuen Weg zu gehen. Das natürlich ohne die Qualität von Neymar, sowohl was sportlich als auch wirtschaftlich angeht, aber man hat Chancen, die sich nicht nur durch diese 222 Millionen ergeben, sondern eben auch durch diese freie Position, durch den neuen Trainer, durch Möglichkeiten auf dem Transfermarkt, durch die Stellung in Spanien, die völlig ohne Diskussion ganz oben ist, neben Real Madrid. Das heißt, man muss es eigentlich aus Barcelona-Sicht positiv sehen, so rum, und einfach einen neuen Weg gehen, versuchen, seine Lösungen zu finden. Wie gesagt, vielleicht auch ein bisschen kreativer denken, als man es bisher getan hat, aber ich denke, dass es dann keinen Bruch geben wird. Da gibt es im Umfeld des Clubs andere Dinge, die eher darauf hindeuten, aber das ist nicht der Transfer von Neymar.
Okay, welche Dinge meinst du da noch ganz kurz?
Also es gibt im Hintergrund von Augusto Benedito, das war ein Präsidentschaftskandidat gegen Bartomeu, ein Misstrauensvotum, der das versucht momentan anzukurbeln. Das ist noch nicht offiziell an den Start gegangen, aber es wird an den Start gehen und da muss man eben gerade abwarten, wie sich jetzt dieser Neymar-Transfer auswirkt auf die abstimmungsberechtigten Fans und Mitglieder. Bisher galt es als sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass da irgendwas passiert, weil auch Bartomeu bei der Präsidentschaftswahl seine Stellung eigentlich klar gesichert hat. Aber gerade, wenn Benedito jetzt das für sich nutzen kann, diesen Abgang von Neymar, der ja durchaus sehr beliebt war eigentlich, sich jetzt aber unbeliebt gemacht hat, das muss man auch dazu sagen. Und wenn er auch noch bestimmte Kooperationen vielleicht findet mit Joaoán Laporta, der eine sehr große Anhängerschaft hat, mit vielen Kritikern, die es auch in Barcelona immer gibt, aufgrund der besonderen Ansprüche, die man im Verein stellt, die man auch an sich selbst stellt, hat er vielleicht eine kleine Chance, ein bisschen was zu bewegen. Das muss man abwarten, das muss man einfach mal sehen. Es gab auch vor den Präsidentschaftswahlen Prognosen, die völlig daneben lagen. Und am Ende hat Bartomeu, der ja mit diesem Sandro Rossell, der jetzt im Gefängnis sitzt, mit Beziehungen nach Katar, nach Brasilien, diese undurchsichtigen Transfers von Spielern wie Douglas beispielsweise, durchaus große Kritikfläche bietet. Da kann man einfach mal abwarten, was passiert. Es ist unglaublich schwer vorherzusagen. Das ist aber eher ein anderes Thema, denke ich, weil es sich schon über Jahre hinweg zieht. Aber dieser Faktor Neymar könnte dem jetzt einen neuen Ton geben vielleicht.
Neues Pulver. Und dann werden wir auch sehen können, spätestens in zwei, drei Jahren werden wir auch sehen, ob das Neymar reicht, in einem Verein zu spielen, wo es dann auf die Ligaspiele gar nicht mehr so ankommt. Gerade wenn jetzt der größte Konkurrent Monaco so geschwächt wird, sollte ein Pape tatsächlich weg sind, wohin auch immer. Es könnte sein, dass da jetzt so ein Domino-Effekt ins Rollen kommt. Ben, vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung. Da bin ich mal gespannt, was sich noch entwickelt, ehrlich gesagt. Ich denke, du freust dich auf La Liga den Start, oder?
Nicht nur wegen Barcelona oder Real, aber auch vielen anderen Teams. Aber ja, es wird auf jeden Fall spannend in Spanien.
Ja, das glaube ich auch. Und das kann man dann verfolgen unter anderem auf TheZone. Das soll hier nicht unter Unerwähnt bleiben. Ben, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast für diesen kurzen Kurzpass. Bis bald mal wieder, ciao.